oh these are not good sounds I've been
meaning to play this but any time I do
like I want to play this game on my own
but I keep quitting because it gets too
much for me and I can't handle it so I
thought if I record that maybe I'll be
okay I love the atmosphere of this and I
also hate it can Stan my god okay it's
just noise --is oh no no no no okay
that's not honorable okay it's fine it's
their normal day in Russia everyone it's
Ukraine isn't it okay let's not engage
with that let's go this way the
atmosphere is that radiation what do we
got over here contain there's okay let's
stay up the roads I like that idea
goddamn look at night it's pretty do I
have weapons I here we go
5000 Russian coins I don't know what
it's called nice okay I feel a little
safer if I have a gun
even though I'll probably miss if
something comes at me but they better
not come at me my only defense is being
loud and obnoxious that's all I got
going for me here okay this road is good
should I go there
sorry I am clueless on how to play this
game by either way so we have our okay
we have some pills no no no oh god stop
this is why I don't play this game stop
stop
I shoot bad start investigate the crash
site
there's the crash site isn't it how did
we get up there
let the Swede explore Ukraine for to see
Jesus getting to the plateau talk to
strangers a new mission I don't think I
can get up here nope alright let's try
and not get murdered at this time that
would be just fantastic
how did that dog see me Oh God
Oh God did he see me did it see me now
they're everywhere all right we're
sneaking through we're snakes in the
bush they'll never find snake oh no not
the dog again no what what is happening
well I will not go there I think I'm
sure about that okay we're fine
Jesus all right there's something over
there let's go there let's avoid the the
wild rat dogs in the process that'd be
just great I want to appreciate the
colors and the aesthetic but also I
don't want to die so I think this is an
old very old indie game and I'm playing
a mod for it called misery whoa what is
happening over there
I don't think trees grow like that oh oh
no oh no oh okay
okie dokie I will back up in the
trenches back away from the trenches Oh
No
Oh Oh God
someone definitely saw me hey hey I was
just leaving anyway it's cool can I jump
okay let's jump over this oh all right
we're okay oh my god this sucks
stop hope hope praise the old gas
station and the scooby-doo mobile all
right radiated will not touch it Jesus
how did this happen other earthquakes in
Ukraine oh god I'm getting radiated but
I also there could be snacks oh god damn
I don't know what the hell I'm doing
okay let's leave this it's morning soon
nice that's nice I can appreciate it
this is waiting for something to charge
at me anything and die that's clearly
this is hardcore right unless I save can
i quick save I can yes okay I'm learning
the SAS sign says book I knew it
alright let's check this place on hey he
Oh
did you guys hear that oh we got dogs
it's not good oh I just want to snack
some meatballs please I'm starving
I need Spain right now I just want food
it supplies maybe oh nice
Ukraine has those weird Chinese toilet
where you squat of course the whole
their whole culture is squatting it
makes perfect sense all right let's go
down shall we
why not all right they got electricity
going can't engage with it
I'm not a fan of this place there must
be something I missed
listen I'm telling you guys I don't know
how to play wild dogs everywhere dude
hello then I'm gonna get aids from the
mosquitos
I don't want it please place mosquitos
oh well well I think we can enter the
flight did someone else kill them
someone shot the dog eat dog Oh
who shot doggie dog
oh my gosh
that's good to know that's something can
just gonna appear out of nowhere
Oh God hi this is my quick save I need
to figure out where I'm going what all
these trees know all right I will get
them I can do it just manage the recall
come at me mother huh I shoot a dog I
don't give up - dogs - doc let's do dog
there's two dogs snake off the dog land
yeah I kill your friend I don't care I
don't care
[ __ ] I'm fine I'm actually bad all
right let's get some soap or bandage
Nega much better
I can barely tell that I've been
attacked by crazy
oh no radiation all right let's try that
again
all right there's dogs up there but
that's where I want to go it's our map
there's a car down there but also dogs
all right what do we got here some sheds
I'm Bolden bankrupt right now this is
all his videos basically let's meet some
strangers see if they can want a drink
hey hey I got a I got a give them my
charm my Swedish charm hey hey oh
alright my Swedish arm couldn't get me
out of that situation I guess look at
these vultures following me tolls I know
what I'm doing all right I'm not gonna
die I have zero deaths so far in this
game
this video is just showing what a Boomer
I am at video games and I don't know how
to play what's up is that Oh tiny people
dude what the hell why are these in the
game dude they got ropes in me I gotta
kill him I got to put him out of their
misery sorry sorry tiny people die
oh shoot all right all right we're good
we're good we're good
nothing against sure people by the way
nothing against them
oh god this is where the octopus guy was
okay Jesus Lord Blatt I said it I said
it I'm such a [ __ ] okay all right here
we go
found a place I can call home it's good
yes it is yes yes yes
oh my god
all right hello friend hat [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] away from here I can't be dealing
with every curious odor that covers by
this is our camp and you got no business
prowling around it
my boys are too started and how you
through it as it is I know what you mean
we don't have much good I feel like this
is what I want to say huh
thanks buddy six pieces of or whatever
clean you can find make sure that to
bring enough to go around so we can move
on and if I smell any of that radiator
crap
and anything you bring us swear to God
get food for the mercenaries hey hey you
want some food well what about me huh
what if I give them their own food or
some stupid all right all right all
right all right all right all right all
right all right
understood understood but it's all right
all right all right
chief's assistant binoculars have you
heard of binoculars we need to find food
this is where the small people were
lived
if they have food then maybe yeah that
could be my end small people love food
everyone knows they appreciate me
can't hit me are they come at me
I hear them they're coming this guy's
closer got him yeah boy another one oh
you got tiny pea pea brain that's what
I'm talking about
stayed that stayed then stay bad what's
happening what is going on there
what is happening I might dragging the
ball what is this why is there a shotgun
flying in front of me
someone's gonna be with me what is that
a second thank you go some shotgun
how are the tiny purse
oh my god I took out my binoculars do
you think you're overreacting a little
bit
people are in H on the Apocalypse all
right here's where the zombie guys are
they had nothing on them anyway let's
stay clear you got to pick your battles
tiny people I'll say Clara them you know
I'll stay clear of them all unless we
know we got to engage I'm not going
anywhere
I just don't remember where that
campsite was job bloody victim what the
[ __ ] was that all right well that's my
cue to [ __ ] off can anyone be nice how
low be nice that a dead body it is oh
look it's Trisha Paytas all right we got
a sub yet knife nice who would have
thought Trisha Paytas would be useful
for anything oh these are not good sound
as much as I can handle for a day hope
you guys enjoyed see you guys never Hey